so I'm still undefeated this uh this
stream
try and keep up the streak chasing 2500
again
my rating took a large zip
in the previous stream
okay we have London
so C6 D6
and just develop
ambition D3
no E5 is uh
lightly move
upon is taking a long time in the
opening which is nice
try and make up some of my time deficits
already threatening uh Knight G5
I have A5 then the G5 I think is strong
that's a move of course
at night's not so happy here
also those pawns under attack
but this Pawn's hanging I don't know
what's going on here
[Music]
um
okay so I'm up upon
still not the most Pleasant position
but okay it's something I think I can
work with all the work to eat is coming
yeah losing the exchange
foreign
what's up Gary
I appreciate the read
if you're just joining this is a
marathon tournament
I'm uh
I'm trying not to lose I'm actually in a
lot of trouble here
I have to say a little bit focused
[Music]
yeah this is not pleasant oh this is
really not pleasant
G3 G5 is coming
this is gonna be my first loss of the
stream unfortunately
oh
foreign
trickery
there is trickery let's go
okay I'm still undefeated this stream
what a funny stalemate
I was thinking about just resigning
because it doesn't seem like the king
can be still needed in the center
but
the key was to give away all the Pawns
shallow tagari thanks for reading in a
nice that's a boy funny moment
top 600 wait what
why does it still say five
I should have gotten like two points for
that I don't understand the scoring
system did I get five points for the
stalemate
maybe I did for still me like that I
deserve the Five Points
okay another game
oh did my point get banned really
that's so funny if my opponent got
banned
maybe that's why I've
I got such a bad position
usually it will notify me though
uh I wanna yeah taking is okay Queen E7
check 95 check
um but should be two maybe
I'm winning the queen
wow
[Music]
I've only got banned
you lost to someone who violated leeches
TOS refund of four Blitz rating points
okay that's nice
and I got this family Trap on top of
that oh wait it says I lost to someone
though
even though I drew someone and
especially even though it feels like I
won with that uh
with what happened